so this is apparently the house from the
u video that you thats cringe do you
know by the l.o.v.e thing in the back I
mean the whole thing I don't know I
don't know the person who sent it to me
swears this is the house that LOV thing
um is pretty distinct right yeah it is
and that little garden is like pretty
[ __ ] similar is this not the the
golden light kitchen I get though I
think it might be dude I think this is
it who found this [ __ ] how did they find
this umm I don't know
damn this is wild it's a million but 1.1
million
it's a depent gets into panget canyon we
can say that I'm in Topanga yeah this
looks like it holy [ __ ] so they were
renting a 1.1 million dollar house 1,900
square feet oh yeah studio as well look
at that pop in bro damn dude that's
crazy they're [ __ ] killing it clearly
there's a studio in there too should we
buy this place
yes buy it man's put all our [ __ ]
it's already got a podcast studio built
into it we put all our chips on this one
just go bankrupt for this [ __ ] house
is the ultimate get back full circle and
we move into the [ __ ] you house dude
that's art Roy Becker move right there
[ __ ] insane we're just just our last
or we blogged ourselves just drinking so
much rose a and does is in straitjackets
hey guys on the ground I know this is
the tiny meet gang podcast but actually
we found our younger 10 year old
brothers who want to run the podcast now
there they're actually 10 years old and
they love celery yes
just going fair enough laughing at the
idea of lying about your age onset being
like [ __ ] so clearly a 35 year old
man and then demanding like your teacher
has to come to set and you have to leave
after six hours and you haven't had your
mandatory three hour break and said I
mean it's definitely illegal right
yeah like let's say you actually got a
gig he's gonna have to like say his real
age
ya know that's what I mean is if your is
like a minor you have to bring a teacher
to set like you can't kid just be out of
school just making your movie you know
but imagine that yeah I'll get back to
my geometry homework later this is my
teacher you guys she's such a stickler
it's this his boy who's like also 24
just you know like you're mrs. Wilson
that's me yep mrs. Wilson I'm a teacher
just weren't easy and a [ __ ] off
white t-shirt yeah mrs. Wilson dude I'm
here to teach Paul I mean Troy [ __ ] [ __ ]
my bad dude [ __ ] when you're wrapped on
when you're wrapped I'm gonna teach you
Pythagoras theorem you know that are you
ready now I mean miss Wilson's coming
through
you